[Thrun] So here's my second piece of software assignments in controls.
In the class we talked about how to make a car follow a straight line.
We used the line x = 0
where the crossing arrow was defined as the y difference between this axis.
We just went off the y value.
So now I want to make a more interesting course, a cyclic course, a racecourse.
Here's my racecourse. It has the radius r, which you can set.
The way I'd like to define this racecourse is through a half cycle where we use r,
same half cycle over here, and the stretches in between I want to be 2r long.
So for example, if this radius equals 25 meters, then this would be 50 meters.
The whole thing would be 100 meters, and this measurement would also be 50 meters.
I want you to program it such that the initial car is stationed right over here,
pointed upwards, and then it drives onto the racecourse like this,
all the way around infinitely often.
The key in doing this is going to be to set a function.
I have already modified for you the function run from our control class
to use that crosstrack_error with the parameter radius,
which we're going to set to 25, but I can pick a different value in my testing.
And then I have modified a little bit the update over here
to maintain the differential and the integral crosstrack_error,
and here is our steering control law that you are familiar with.
Instead of twiddle I'm just going to give you parameters, 10, 15, and 0.
Those work fine for me,
and they're actually the result of running twiddle without the integral part.
And then when I run it, I get my output. And here it is.
The crosstrack_error by and large is very small.
You can see the steering tends to be on the negative side.
Here we're steering at the first turn, here we're on the straightaway.
You can see this by the numbers.
Here we go into a turn again, so the turning becomes larger.
In all of this you find the crosstrack_error to be relatively small,
about 0.1 or so--not very much--and this continues and continues.
The final crosstrack_error for the second half of the race is 0.005.
So you want this number to be really, really small.
The tricky part is when you code this up and code the function cte,
you need a different branch for this area here, for this area over here,
this area over here, this area over here.
Keep in mind that the robot is going to go in a cycle.
So it's going to traverse this one in the opposite direction with this one over here.
So good luck coding up the correct crosstrack_error function.